[Applause]
ukraine and russia have finally reached
an agreement to ship millions of tons of
grain and fertilizer to the rest of the
world
u.n secretary general antonio gutierrez
the architect of the deal has praised
the two countries for setting aside
their differences
and let there be no doubt this is an
agreement for the world
it will bring relief for developing
countries on the edge of bankruptcy and
the most vulnerable people on the edge
of famine the initiative we just signed
opens a pass
for significant volumes of commercial
food exports from three key ukrainian
ports in the black sea
odessa
chebonorsk and useni
the shipment of grain and foodstocks
into world markets will help bridge the
global food supply gap and reduce
pressure on high prices
since russia invaded ukraine in february
global food prices have increased and
several countries are facing famines
turkey which helped to facilitate this
accurate will host a joint coordination
and control center in istanbul to
oversee the grain exports
we all know that there will be no losers
in a just piece i sincerely wish that
this joint step that we are taking today
in istanbul with the russian and
ukrainian sides will be a new turning
point that will revive hopes for peace
no matter which way the developments in
the field take the war will eventually
end at the negotiating table
as guaranteers the un and turkey have
signed two separate agreements one with
russia and one with ukraine presidential
adviser mikhail podoliak has emphasized
that kiev's obligations are only to the
un and turkey while defense minister
sergey shoigu has promised moscow won't
take advantage of the deal
the parties have agreed that russian
naval ships will not accompany vessels
into ukrainian ports and if necessary
the cargo will be jointly inspected in
turkish waters
bringing russia and ukraine together has
been no easy feat it's a diplomatic high
point for antonio guterres in his five
years as u.n secretary general but in
order to achieve its goal of eliminating
hunger the agreement will need to be
executed in full
that's why he'll be monitoring
procedures closely
cinema al jazeera istanbul